hi everyone my name is frank wendt
i am a genetic epidemiologist in the
division of human genetics
in the department of psychiatry at the
yale school of medicine um and today
i'll be presenting some data
that my collaborators and i have put
together
aiming to leverage bioinformatic
resources to better tackle
challenging biological substrates and
dna profiles
i don't have any conflicts of interest
to disclose and i have no relevant
funding for the data presented today
a very brief overview i am going to give
a little bit of a background
on some of the concepts in the forensic
genetics and genomics community before i
dive into bullet points two and three
which are some data that we've been
putting together for two projects
and then we'll wrap up with just some
next steps in big picture information
so diving into some of the background
here this should be fairly familiar for
everyone but in
the the presence of a relatively diverse
audience we will go through some
some basics um humans have 22 autosomes
22 pairs of autosomes
one of each chromosome is inherited from
you know both parents and we also have
one pair of sex chromosomes that are
shown on the bottom right
of that yellow square the x and y
chromosomes
the presence of a y chromosome dictating
the biological male sex
within the human body chromosomes are
contained in cells which are contained
in organs which are
all over our body and if we go sort of
the other direction
looking really closely at what's within
a chromosome we see that this
this oblong structure can unwind and
unwind and unwind and we ultimately end
up at this
string of a's t's g's and c's that are
contained within our dna
and this will be the focus of our talk
today these a's tgs and c's
tell our cellular machinery how to make
the appropriate pieces of what goes on
in our body what those pieces are
supposed to do and when those pieces
should stop doing what they're supposed
to do
so in the forensic science community we
focus on
primarily two types of genetic variation
for identifying individuals the first is
the short tandem repeat
shown here on the top of the slide
in blue and purple i'm showing the
pieces of dna that could be inherited
from the maternal or paternal side
of your your background from the
paternal side we see that this
individual received three copies of that
gata
sequence from the maternal side we see
that this person
received four copies of that gata
sequence
at this str locus this person would be
considered a 3
4 indicating the length of those
alleles epilocus for single nucleotide
polymorphisms we see a much different
structure here in red i'm highlighting
this
snip motif we see that from the maternal
side this individual received the g
allele and from the paternal side this
person received the t
allele so both of these things are used
in forensic science and both of them
have some benefits and some drawbacks
strs are highly variable they're really
good at distinguishing people from from
everybody else we don't need a lot of
them
but because they are so large and
because they are repetitive they can
have some problems
um with their amenability to the
chemistry that we use to genotype these
types of loci snips on the other hand
are less variable they are still pretty
good at distinguishing two people but we
need many more of them to do so
and they don't suffer from the same
chemistry issues that we have with strs
so in certain circumstances these could
be really useful choices
um to pick an str versus a snip based on
your question
so in the uh forensic science community
strs are kind of considered the gold
standard especially for casework
we're seeing here on the bottom right of
the screen an electro ferrogram derived
from pcr ce approaches
if i zoom in on one of these positions
we see that
the electropherogram here shows at one
locus
the three four allele designations that
we see in the person
on the top of the screen the heights of
those two triangles or peaks
are a little bit different from one
another and that reflects different
relative fluorescence units
um derived from the capillary
capillary electrophoretic procedure that
these go through
we can also have an instance where we
observe uh several alleles at a locus
so in this example i'm now showing you
that same locus but we have
four triangles or four peaks um so is
this a one-person profile is this a
two-person profile is this a
three-person profile
um we can occasionally with some
additional information
say hey we found a match um it's a
two-person mixture our victim
is a four-five so they carry four copies
and five copies of that str
um our person of interest is a three-six
but what does that actually mean what do
we do with this information
we can perform some statistics that rely
heavily on population genetics
on the right side of the screen i'm
showing the distribution of allele
frequencies
for this hypothetical locus in three
united states population groups
european american in green african
american and yellow and asian american
in orange
we can use this information to calculate
the rarity
of observing the person of interests uh
alleles at this locus and typically
all of these uh combined estimates in
the table here
would be a network report uh related to
this profile
so i'm not going to touch on the
chemistry of massively parallel
sequencing but i do want to introduce
the the power that this has
especially in terms of mixture
deconvolution so on the left side of the
screen we see
sort of the same scenario i've been
showing on the last couple of slides
we have a couple of alleles at a locus
by length we may make some assumptions
about whether or not this is a
two-person three-person one-person
mixture
um if i give you if i gave you some more
context and said that the victim
is a three-four you might say okay the
the other contributor or contributors
might be a 4-6 or even a 4-4
but what if i gave you more context and
said that there's only one other
contributor you may then say okay we can
make some pretty confident assumptions
that this is
a a 3 4 mixed with a 4 6.
but massively parallel sequencing lets
us take this a little bit further and
say i can actually tell you what part of
that 4 peak
came from our victim and what part of
that four peak
came from our person of interest and
this is done using the sequence level
information
that is contained in each of those
triangles so we can break apart
um that four triangle into two pieces
the red part that may belong to the
victim for example and the blue part
that may belong to our person of
interest
so now moving into some of the actual
studies that we're doing in the context
of mixtures
and some of these more complex dna
profiles
so first i want to introduce um the sort
of rationale behind why
we have started predicting str genotypes
from identity informative snips
so um i've i've presented both of these
types of loci on the last couple of
slides
um we know that strs are highly
polymorphic we know that they have
larger amplicon sizes but they do tend
to suffer from pcr artifacts
and this makes them especially
difficult to really get good information
from
in the context of a compromised
substrate such as human remains
or a substrate that may be heavily
environmentally insulted from something
like humic acids
on the contrary the snips are smaller
amplicons so so degradation may not be
as much of an issue
they don't have pcr artifacts so
untangling stutter from true peaks may
not be a problem
they are also less polymorphic so we do
need many more of them
um but they are easier to type and
compromise substrates
so much of the approach to tackling sort
of challenging human remains or
challenging environmentally
salted samples has been from the side of
the chemistry
we've taken a different approach and
said what if we just use the data that
we can get from the identity informative
snips
and better use the data that we can get
from this profile
so to do this uh we rely on a process
called imputation
and this is basically a statistical
inference of unobserved genotypes
at the str loci of interest using
identity informative sniff loci of
interest
so this relies heavily on the concept of
linkage disequilibrium between
snips and strs in
a diagram on the right side of the
screen i'm showing sort of roughly how
this works
um if we have our study samples that
contain our snip haplotype of interest
we also have a set of reference
information that includes
typically whole genome sequenced
reference panels
that include our strs in the black box
and our snips of interest
all in the same read and then we can
basically perform a vlookup or look up
our haplotype
in our reference and say okay this
matches and then i can put a weight
to how well it matches and what i think
the
gaps are in the str locus
so we performed this process
in a couple ways and i'll show that on
the next two slides
but first we identified strs that were
in high linkage disequilibrium with
snips of interest from the forensic dna
signature prep kit
um we evaluated their heterozygosities
we compared some
random match probability information and
then we're also investigating a leave
one out analysis
to investigate how some incompleteness
of your ii snip profile
may actually contribute to the data that
you can receive
in forms of str genotypes
so to very quickly summarize uh why
we're doing this
str's likely won't work well in the
context of compromised human remains
uh snips could work a little bit better
uh partial snip profiles
may actually in in our study be
predictive
of partial sdr profiles such that the
random match probability could become a
little bit better
and then ultimately the long term here
is to test whether or not what we're
doing in the computer actually reflects
what happens
in real life
so here is a uh study overview we took
two
sort of sets of snips the first was uh
an entire
snipper raise information of like you
know several million snips
uh we also then reduced that snip count
to only the 94 identity informative
snips from the forensic dna
signature prep kit we performed snipster
imputation and then we compared
the heterozygosities and allele counts
for three sets of strs the codus loci
the navroski at all 73 plex and the
highly concordant strs that we
identified through this procedure
so this work is primarily been
spearheaded by angelica who is a
master's student in nicole navroski's
lab at the university of toronto
she took these 222 snips which
represents the 94 ii snip amplicons
we received just over or sorry just
under
170 000 strs imputed
67 000 of those had global
heterozygositys greater than zero
and 24 000 of those had heterozygosities
greater than 25
in uh three major global population
groups of interest
we did use the thousand genomes project
for this
and we asked two primary questions
what's going on with codis
and the navroski at all 73 plex and then
what's going on with the other loci that
we found that were actually imputed
really well
so first um under ideal conditions so
when we gave the procedure the entire
snip arrays worth of information
um the codis loci and the nebroski at
all 73 plex
generally imputed pretty well so when we
compared this
to the imputation using just the ii
snips we only identified three snips
or sorry three strs that actually gave
us some meaningful information in terms
of amputation success
in terms of concordance with the
heterozygosity and allele spread with
the the truth data
these include one of the nebraska at all
loci and then two of the codus loci
listed here
what's more interesting is that we
actually found 545 str's that were well
imputed using our 94 iii snips
i'm showing here the heterozygosities of
those
strs in three of our population groups
using the ii snip
and the snip array information those are
pretty similar really nice overlap and
the allele spreads are actually
perfect between the two of them so our
next steps
um because the heterozygosities of these
loci were quite low they're probably not
super useful for hid so human identity
purposes
so we are currently characterizing their
ancestry effects as well as some of the
phenotypic consequences of these
554 or sorry 545 strs
this manuscript is in preparation uh
with angelica taking the lead
um under the mentorship of nicole broski
so next we'll look at simulating
mixtures um
very briefly what does it mean to
simulate data we actually do all of this
on the computer so we can take
real-world scenarios and then
make data out of these real-world
scenarios
the value of doing this is that we have
a lot of control over what conditions
affect the data that we produce this is
both time
and cost effective and scales to very
large sample sizes
which is really really great for early
career investigators like myself
one of the major limitations to this
that i will be super
transparent about throughout the
presentation is whether or not there is
some sampling error or stochasticity
in how these data are simulated
so i'm showing here also a picture of an
undergraduate student ashley
in nicole navrati's lab she has been
instrumental in putting all of this work
together
so i do also want to make sure that she
gets the the shout out that she deserves
so we used the r package forensim that
was developed
as a set of tools to study and interpret
dna mixtures
we used this package to simulate
genotypes and mixtures and population
data based on published allele
frequencies
the package also allows you to perform
some statistical interpretation of the
data that you generate
we'll be focusing on the likelihood
ratios but there are a whole bunch of
other
statistics that you can generate in
forensim
so our overall goal was to assess the
reproducibility and dementability of
forensim to large population genetic and
mixture studies
we relied on the population allele
frequency data from nabroski at all in
2016
using african-american asian-american
european-american and hispanic
population groups
all of which have been genotyped for
strs in the
forensic dna signature prep kit
our study design included generating 50
population replicates of each of our
target populations for a total of 38
900 individuals um we performed a couple
of population genetic parameters on
these uh 50 replicates and then compared
those back to
the nicole naroski estimates we then
took
all of the individuals that we were
studying
and created 2400 same ancestry mixtures
what that means is that we took two
people of african-american
from the african-american cohort mixed
them together and then performed our
mixture matched statistics using those
individuals
so our primary end point here was the
likelihood ratios
and we did compare those back to uh the
same likelihood ratio or sorry the
likelihood ratio for the same profile
calculated with nabroski at all
um and i do want to point out here that
for
simplicity all of our likelihood ratios
assume the most
basic uh
numerator and denominator so we
essentially said that all of the alleles
observed in the profile can be explained
by
this person versus cannot be explained
by that person
so in the context of a more complicated
or several alternative hypotheses
much of the data that i present today
may not hold
so looking at our population genetic
information we're showing here in panel
a the distribution of hardy-weinberg
equilibrium p-values
across our four american population
groups
we see the vertical dashed line
indicates the nominally significant
p-value of 0.05
so everything to the left of that line
indicates a significant deviation from
hardy-weinberg equilibrium
at least at the nominally significant
level we tabulate what those
deviations look like across all of the
strs
in the forensic panel in object b
here we see that there is really no
indication that a specific locus
is causing a problem here and actually
when we perform our multiple testing
correction
we still see that this is not really any
indicator that a specific str is giving
us issues in terms of our simulated
population data
unfortunately our pattern of significant
deviations from hardy-weinberg
equilibrium
also look very different from what uh
navroski had all observed
in the 2016 article
in terms of allele frequencies i'm
showing here
in black the point estimates in the 95
confidence intervals from nebraska at
all
in red blue purple and green i'm showing
the point estimates
from our 50 simulated populations you'll
see that all of those distributions do
fall within the 95
confidence intervals of navrovsky at all
and this was initially really exciting
to us
but as we thought about it a little bit
more um
we became curious about how these even
minor changes
in allele frequency distribution could
impact the resulting match
statistics for either single source
profiles or a mixed dna profile
so we went on to test how that may
affect
what our mixture statistics look like so
here we have our simulated mixture
results
for two-person three-person and
four-person mixtures again we are only
using same ancestry
uh combinations of individuals so in the
top left there that afa
box we are only looking at two-person
mixtures
both of whom are of african-american uh
or both of whom are from our
african-american cohort
we took that mixture and we calculated
likelihood ratios for all 200 of the
mixtures we created
and those likelihood ratios were derived
using allele frequencies from all four
populations
and what we're showing here is that
in every instance the true contributor
population is
the one producing the least prejudicial
um likelihood ratios and this is a
really good sign this was more of a
sanity check for us
um to make sure that the mixtures we
created and the populations we generated
are giving us estimates that we expect
to see in the real world
i will point out that as we move into
that hispanic column
we do see that a a relatively large
proportion of the non-contributor
likelihood ratios fall below that
diagonal dashed line
indicating that the least prejudicial
estimate of the likelihood ratio
actually came from
a non-contributor population group
and i think that this ultimately has
some pretty major implications for
mixtures including highly admixed
population groups
so here we're showing how your choice of
population replicate influences the
distribution of likelihood ratios across
all 200 of the mixtures that we created
per facet or per group
of individuals so on the x-axis we're
showing the standardized mean difference
and this is really just a way to
better capture the magnitude of effect
size between two distributions
given the standard deviation across
everybody from those two
uh groups on the y-axis we're looking at
the
minus log 10 p-value for the fdr
adjusted p-value
so the higher the data point the more
significant the difference between
um our distribution of likelihood ratios
and nicole nabroski's distribution of
likelihood ratios
so what you'll notice here is that first
and foremost there are a lot of data
points in all four of those facets that
are above the dashed line
this indicates that we saw a ton of
significant differences when compared to
the
distributions from nebraska at all i do
also want to point out here that with
the exception of the asian american
population over half of all of the other
population groups
produced a significantly different
likelihood ratio distribution
um which is suggesting to us that you
know your
your choice of replicate and and even
just using one replicate
may not be very sufficient in terms of
accurately modeling what you think
should happen with the data that you've
truly genotyped
i do also want to point out here that in
the eu a
facet that's the european americans we
see three populations that we simulated
that actually had
extremely large effect sizes or
standardized mean differences sorry
and extremely significant p values so
all of these negative
data points on the x-axis indicate that
our simulate simulated populations
produced larger uh log-10 likelihood
ratios so the the profile was actually
indicated as being more rare than it
would have been in the nebraska at all
estimate
so that's fine but do those results
uh suggest that maybe we have an issue
with just a couple of mixtures that went
into the analyses
so here we're showing the uh
how the number of replicate populations
chosen
influences the likelihood ratio
distributions per
uh per mixture so each data point here
represents a mixture
those are shown on the left side of each
violin plot whereas the actual
distribution of data is shown on the
right side of each violin plot
on the x-axis we're showing the number
of replicates that was included
in the calculation of the mean
likelihood ratio
on the y axis we're showing the
difference between that mean
and the nebraska at all estimate um
as we increase the number of replicates
this is unsurprising
that we sort of reduce the distribution
of mean differences
thankfully it's being reduced to
hovering around zero suggesting that
there is little to no difference between
um the replicated populations and the
nebroski at all populations
however um i'm only showing the the afa
subset here just to
to make the point more clear um
after multiple testing correction we
identify that this
choice of 10 replicate populations going
into your mixture study
is where we seem to converge on uh the
narrowest distribution
relative to the original distribution so
the means from 10 replicates onward tend
to hover around zero and those
distributions
have the smallest variance relative to
uh just picking one replicate
so you'll see here that the actual
distribution of differences in that one
replicate
violin plot are not super large so for
two person
mixtures this may not be super
meaningful to include a bunch of
replicates
although we still think that
statistically this is a significant
observation
when we look at the i believe these are
the three person mixtures
we see a very different story we are
still identifying 10 replicates
as being a really good spot for us to to
you know
target in terms of how many times should
we ascertain this data
however what we're not seeing is that
narrowing of the distribution
all of our means do tend to reduce
closer to zero
but we still have a substantial number
of individuals on the extreme ends of
our distribution
such that the variance does not change
among these
uh these observations so in some
instances so maybe these three and four
person mixtures
um we have not actually identified an
appropriate number of replicates yet
with which to sort of get a meaningful
useful and high confidence estimate of
what's actually going on
so to summarize here
when using modeling tools it's really
important to
uh pay attention to some comprehensive
assessments of the reliability of those
tools
and really the impetus behind us doing
this project is that we didn't feel like
we had
literature for that to support our use
of friend
in some of these projects that we want
to do so here we demonstrated that the
forensim data works really well or sorry
the the forensin package works really
well with the nebraska at all data
it is fast it is efficient we can look
at really large sample sizes
but we have not demonstrated that our
observations that i presented you
to you today can generalize outside of
the nebraska adult data
so this is sort of a natural next step
for what we're currently working on
um we do want to note that the allele
frequency range was
quite broad even though this was
contained within the 95
confidence interval of our point
estimates from nebroski at all
we did identify a number of
hardy-weinberg equilibrium deviations
um and we think in combination this
could indicate
that uh there may be some uh residual
population stratification that is being
um induced using the forensim procedure
and this is likely a result of
us simulating the exact sample size of
nebraska at all
um in the event that there are rare
alleles in the nebraska at all data set
if we are simulating the same data set
size we can only sample
some of those rare alleles so many times
and if they are not
in the right combination we may observe
very different hardy-weinberg
equilibrium deviations
from uh what was actually observed with
the nebraska
at all data
so in all of our analyses using a single
simulated population to calculate
likelihood ratios was extremely noisy
i think that we can confidently say that
one replicate in this type of analysis
using simulated data
is not sufficient to garner any type of
confident estimate in what's going on
with that mixture
we tended to uh highlight
a population replicate count of 10
although this may be able to
uh go down a little bit if we considered
a minor allele frequency adjustment
which we did not do in our study
so it is very common to apply this 5
over 2n
threshold or or adjustment to alleles
observed fewer than x
number of times and while this may have
reduced our population replicate counts
uh our data did not uh tend to support
that low frequency alleles or profiles
or mixtures that carry low frequency
alleles
were the origin of the large
distribution in likelihood ratio
differences that we observed so
given many of the hardy-weinberg
equilibrium deviations that we observed
many of the hispanic population
non-contributor likelihood ratios that
we observed
we have sort of a standing hypothesis
that
our results have some pretty
considerable implications for cross
ancestry mixtures um and these are
currently
um underway uh being led by
students from the nicole debroski's lab
so the manuscript describing the
uh the data i presented today is
currently in review so i ask you to
patiently await the output from that
i do want to give a shout out to both
ashley and dr nabroski for
their tremendous support and initiative
in getting some of this data
you know really running instead of just
walking
so uh finally some acknowledgements um
again to dr navroski and her lab at the
university of toronto
who've been super supportive and working
really hard at getting some of these
projects
going dr hinda haned who is the creator
of the forensim r package
um ultimately we couldn't do the project
if the package didn't exist so
um hats off to her for putting this out
into the world
uh and finally dr rory rolfes and nico
caberio at sfsu
for really enthusiastic discussions over
the last year about the social and legal
implications of ancestry race and
ethnicity
on mixture interpretation i do
anticipate that many of these
discussions will form some hypotheses
for
some long-term future collaborative
efforts uh so finally
uh if there are questions i do encourage
you to reach out to myself
or dr navroski our contact information
is here
twitter um email website contacts those
are all fair game
um and finally finally um i did want to
put out the
special announcement that i am guest
editing
a special issue of genes titled source
attribution using forensic genomics
the deadline for this is excuse me
october 20th of this year if you do have
questions about submission
feel free to contact myself or any of
the editorial staff through the
manuscript submission system we will
hopefully
get you rocking and rolling as soon as
possible
and i appreciate your consideration for
submitting to us
and with that i don't think i can in
person take any questions unless it's
via email
absolutely entertain the option for
questions through either
endeavor and that is all i thank you for
your attention